[Musique]
c'est l'assemblée annuelle de berkshire
hathaway à omaha au nebraska warren
buffett 91 ans et charlie munger 98 ce
sont toujours les associés surtout
l'inspiration de bien des investisseurs
dont deux ce soir que nous recevons
c'est notre siège du vendredi avec aaron
l'ani gestionnaire de portefeuille chez
12h06 et marc l'écuyer gestionnaire de
portefeuille chez cote 100 tous les deux
à omaha au nebraska bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous pourquoi c'est
important avant de l'ani d'abord d'être
d'être présent à cet endroit pour cet
événement pour vous
oui pour nous il ya quelques raisons
alors c'est sûr et il commence à être
angers et donc on sait jamais si la
dernière fournée mois ensuite il ya
plusieurs événements
personne
pour vous marc l'écuyer quels sont les
signification particulière d'être
présent aujourd'hui
pour nous aussi le plus important c'est
peut-être côtoyer des gens qui partagent
c'est la première assemblée qui se tient
en personne depuis 2019 la première fois
en trois ans que tout le monde peut bien
sûr se retrouver aaron l'anis et c'est
quoi l'ambiance parce qu'on voit qui est
de la circulation derrière vous est ce
que tout le monde est là est ce que est
ce que c'est il ya de l'optimisme dans
l'air comment ça se passe
mais on voit que ça semble années
précédentes
compte
déplacer
facilement on s'attend à quoi en fin de
semaine marc l'écuyer de 2,2 la présence
bien sûr de voir une bouffée de
challenger des interventions qu'est ce
qu'est ce que vous attendez de cette fin
de semaine
quelques attentes notamment au niveau de
peut-être comme les deux excuses à de
fortes chaleurs voit les perspectives
pour les prochaines années au niveau du
marché parce que on est quand même dans
une période assez certaine en ce moment
donc on obtient
de voir c'est quoi leur vision
des relations
des enjeux économiques peut-être aussi
au niveau des acquisitions on a vu une
question assez importante qui était
annoncé l'acquisition d'allegheny donc
on aimerait savoir un petit peu leur le
rationnel en arrière de ça il ya
peut-être d'autres acquisitions qui va
se matérialiser le
départ de l'année de votre compte et
qu'est ce que vous allez chercher en
fait semaine qu'est ce que vous voulez
entendre
qu'est ce qui est important pour vous
vous pouvez enfin pu
actionner
attentes
mais c'est sûr qu'on aimerait savoir ni
moyen qui va déployer pour tenter de
gêner mais
alors dans les
super forme il est donc plus qu'un parti
dit c'est commun qu'ils ont déployés
dans 57 milliards da
soit dans des régions une répulsion
d'entreprises privées ou d'entreprises
publiques alors c'est comme un crime
capital
les actionnaires et en fait les
investisseurs au sens large plaie
gestionnaire que vous êtes
avait toujours une grande confiance
envers ces deux hommes là et leur vision
pour notre part nous on a toujours une
grande confiance
d'avoir confiance dans la relève parce
que probablement qui le restera encore
beaucoup d'années
ma confiance mal placée
oui on a confiance non seulement les
sujets actuels mais tenir en mars vous
l'avez évoqué marque écuyer d'ailleurs
warren buffett a réalisé quand même une
importante acquisition est la plus la
plus importante en sept ans leurs achats
de l'entreprise allait gagny dont le pdg
joe brandon est quand même d'amis de
longue date de warren buffett pourquoi
cette acquisition est importante qu'est
ce que ça signifie au juste
pour nous ce que cela signifie c'est que
ne s'est pas fait foi des occasions dans
le marché à ce
point important c'est cacher des
activités notre crise qui connaît très
bien qu'à l'accepter d'assurance
réassurance sont des activités sont
connexes aux activités de pêcheurs donc
c'est une logique derrière la
transaction mais simplement de la
réaliser la transaction c'est aussi une
indication que ce soit le support fait
et positifs quant aux perspectives d'un
long terme
en février challenger dit aaron la nuit
il a dit que les crypto monnaie devrait
être interdite qu'est ce que vous en
pensez et est ce que tout le monde
adhère à cette vision note
simple en dehors de notre servent de
compétences et moi
fondamental c'est plus un tribunal aux
yeux
on passe pourtant de nous a tenté
d'analyser ce marché
est ce que donne la niche et vous chez
midi si le
travail que vous faites la philosophie
qui est derrière ça puis en tout ou en
partie sur les principes de warren
buffett et de challenger
déficit au niveau de l'analyse marcheurs
ce qu'on fait donc de payer un prix
juste mon entreprise que les avantages
concurrentiels et qui voit trois
marques on communie avec nos clients
dans la transparence
en effet
il les suit
au marché ces éléments ont cherché
et vous voyez cuir chez vous de votre
côté à côte sans
qu'aucun ou tout à fait on regarde
l'historique de performance
parce que démontrer à long terme qu'elle
avait créé beaucoup de richesse pour les
actionnaires oui on essaie de répliquer
cette philosophie de six semaines de
coma
l'acquéreur des entreprises prises de
balle à la cuisse sont bien gérées des
allemandes et de tenir à long terme par
une année en terminant on a toujours dit
que c'était l'événement le woodstock du
capitalisme est ce que vous le voyez
comme ça
oui sur des gens qui sont munis pour une
raison
c
est ce que c'est pour pourvoir nani le
point central de votre année est-ce que
c'est capital ce qui se passe en fin de
semaine pour un investisseur
est-ce que c'est capital
le regard des victimes en chine ue ça
mais c'est juste comme ça tout d'un
réseau thé avec des gens à personnes
d'échanger des idées
puis si jamais l'équipe si c'est une fan
ses actifs et
j'en doute pas un seul instant la
flicaille élections terminées
oui mais nous aussi on trouve que c'est
important d'être présent ici j'
notamment pour les plus jeunes dans
notre équipe peut-être qu'ils ont jamais
vécu l'expérience
ça vaut la peine de le vivre au moins
une fois à présent
excellent ben je vous souhaite une belle
fin de semaine merci beaucoup à rennes
la nii marc l'écuyer on aimera ce cas la
rencontre de berkshire hathaway merci
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit